what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like the Fantastic Four
reboot isn't going to be exactly what we
thought it was going to be or it might
be exactly what you thought that may
sound a bit confusing but I will explain
everything in this video we have a brand
new report today about the Fantastic
Four involving Galactus and the Silver
Surfer but we also do have some casting
news today and it looks like some
casting reports that we got in the past
could have been wrong but the person
that Marvel Studios could possibly want
to play Mr Fantastic might shock you a
little bit now right off the bat Kevin
feige has already stated that the
Fantastic Four movie that we're going to
get in the MCU in 2025 isn't necessarily
going to be an origin story yes it's
going to be a reboot and I'm sure they
are going to talk about and possibly
even give us a glimpse on how they got
their powers but I don't think they're
going to be focusing too much on how
they originally became the Fantastic
Four this will sort of kind of be like
Civil War how we got Spider-Man in it we
didn't ever really get the Spider-Man
origin story but that's because in Kevin
feige said this we all already knew it
now Spider-Man is one of the most
popular characters of all time in
superhero history and the Fantastic Four
are pretty popular too however I would
say they at least need to give us a
glimpse into the past on how the
Fantastic Four got their powers or at
least talk about it however having said
that I do like the idea of just jumping
into a story and based off of some new
reports from some insiders it looks like
the story is going to be really really
interesting now when we originally heard
that the Fantastic Four wasn't exactly
going to be an origin story we didn't
really think that we would get anything
like the Silver Surfer or Galactus in
this movie because Kevin feige doesn't
really like to repeat things that have
been done in the past he likes to keep
it fresh however Galactus in the
original Fantastic Four the rez of the
Silver Surfer movie wasn't really
Galactus it was done terribly terribly
wrong which is kind of a good thing
because now Evan feige can come in and
make Galactus as he is supposed to be
now Galactus is coming and he's going to
be hinted at in the Fantastic Four
setting him up for something huge in the
future which we'll talk about in just a
bit however the Silver Surfer will play
a significant part in the Fantastic Four
reboot according to The Insider my time
to shine hello who has a great track
record with her Scoops she says the
Silver Surfer is gonna be in the
Fantastic Four reboot it's also worth
mentioning that Alex P from the cosmic
circus also retweeted this with a
smiling Emoji which further backs up
this report and the cosmic circus has
been extremely accurate with their
reports recently as well so the new
Fantastic Four movie is going to include
the Silver Surfer in it now as most
people know the Silver Surfer is the
herald of Galactus his job is to scout
out worlds for Galactus to devour to
consume to destroy and it looks like the
Silver Surfer is going to be making his
way to Earth in the Fantastic Four
reboot however I do not believe that the
silver surface is going to be the main
plot point of the Fantastic Four movie
however the Silver Surfer is simply
arriving has extremely huge implications
like I mentioned before the Silver
Surfer means Galactus is coming and
again the account my time to shine hello
even tweeted in regards to Galactus
replying to her other tweet about the
Silver Surfer stating and yet no
Galactus just a hint so since we're just
getting a hint at Galactus that leads me
to believe that the Silver Surfer will
most likely come in at the end of the
movie perhaps maybe even in the
post-credits scene because the Silver
Surfer definitely means the arrival of
Galactus but since Galactus is only
hinted at in this film perhaps a tiny
little name drop or maybe the Silver
Surfer saying something like my master
is coming to devour this world that
probably means that the Silver Surfer is
not the main antagonist of the Fantastic
Four movie but will most likely come in
towards the end or in a post-credits
scene now as far as the actual plot is
concerned for the Fantastic Four movie
I'm assuming that it's going to somewhat
Connect into the king Dynasty and Secret
Wars I believe Reed Richards is going to
be one of the main characters of both of
these movies and I believe he's going to
be an extremely important character
because after all he is the smartest man
alive and I believe they're going to
need him and the entire Fantastic Four
team to truly learn about incursions
plus to truly travel the Multiverse I'm
assuming the Fantastic Four will be
connected to the quantum realm in some
shape or form perhaps the quantum realm
is even in their origin story perhaps
they got their powers from the quantum
realm so this could mean that Reed
Richards using time travel technology
and the quantum realm could figure out a
way to truly jump through the Multiverse
and this could be how all of the
variants finally come together in
Avengers Secret Wars now as far as who
is going to be playing The Fantastic
Four characters my time to shine hello
offers even more updates for us and as
it turns out she says that pin Badgley
was never considered for the role of
Reed Richards the other day somebody
posted a picture saying I have your MCU
Fantastic Four right here with pin badge
actually being listed for Reed Richards
in which she replied pin Badgley was
never even considered for Reed now of
course this goes against other reports
that we've gotten in the past but like I
said my time to shine Hello's track
record is very very good which leads us
to believe that this could be accurate
now the recent rumor and to be clear
it's just a rumor is that Diego Luna
could be Mr Fantastic now right away let
me know what you think about this
possible casting in the comments down
below I'm very curious to hear what you
think about this but what is really
interesting about this is that not too
long ago Grace Randolph said that she
heard that somebody from the Star Wars
franchise could be plain Mr Fantastic
and of course Diego Luna is from the
Star Wars franchise so there actually
could be some Merit to this and Diego
Luna has recently responded to these
rumors in an interview here's what he
had to say in an interview with
Christian harloff as far as if if you
could is Marvel something that you'd be
interested in doing if the opportunity
arose I just I just like the
um
I was talking about about that this
morning like
the rumors when you become part of
rumors
like if half of the rumors were real you
know it's it's just incredible the
amount of stuff oh man that uh that I
see now out there uh
the only thing I can tell you about is
that for the next
two years I'm busy right okay and in two
years we'll see if
what I want to do is
now this is a very interesting response
because of course he does not deny this
he actually says that he's going to be
busy for the next two years now I don't
want to speculate too heavily and get
everybody's hopes up if you do want to
go Luna to play Mr Fantastic but a part
of me thinks that he could be the next
two years filming the Fantastic Four the
Fantastic Four is pretty much two years
away a little over two years it comes
out in February of 2025 and we're about
to be in February of 2023 in a couple of
months what also makes it pretty
interesting is that the only upcoming
project that Diego Luna has right now is
a project called La Macarena it's going
to be a TV mini-series but I don't see
that taking up two years of his time
especially if he doesn't have a major
role in it so it is possible that he
could be talking about the Fantastic
Four here my time to shine hello has
also stated that right now Isa Gonzalez
is the top choice for Sue storm now some
of you may know her she's been in a lot
she's been in Fast and Furious presents
Hobbes and Shaw and of course Godzilla
vs Kong and I believe the most recent
movie that she did was Ambulance with
Jake Gyllenhaal and what's actually very
interesting is that she is also going to
be in La Macarena with Diego Luna so is
it possible that the two of them Isa and
Diego are indeed going to be Mr
Fantastic and The Invisible Woman it's a
possibility but of course we're gonna
have to wait and see how that plays out
now as far as Galactus arriving in the
MCU is concerned it doesn't sound like
he's going to really be in the Fantastic
Four reboot but will most likely be in a
second movie of theirs I don't think
that Galactus is going to come and be a
part of the King Dynasty or Avengers
Secret Wars as much as I want Galactus
to come I really don't see how he would
fit very well into the story of either
movie plus I think he would get kind of
overshadowed with everything that would
be happening in those movies so I think
the safe bet would be to have him in his
own Fantastic Four movie or to Simply
have him in another Avengers movie maybe
the first Avengers movie that takes
place after Secret Wars because a
villain unlike Galactus truly does
deserve to have his time he doesn't
deserve just to be thrown into something
very quickly and then get out of the MCU
quickly as well he needs to be in the
MCU for a decent amount of time and I'm
assuming that he's going to be coming
during the Fantastic Four in the expense
time which is going to be during phase
seven this would also give us fans
something to really look forward to
after the huge events of the King
Dynasty and Secret Wars so hinting that
Galactus is coming in Phase 7 would give
fans something to really really look
forward to after we get secret Wars
where there could be kind of a lull in
fans eyes and hopefully this way we
don't have to kind of deal with another
phase four another rebuilding phase this
way we could go straight into the
Fantastic Four the X-Men and the arrival
of Galactus and hopefully all of the
heroes teaming up the X-Men the
Fantastic Four and whoever's left of the
Avengers to fight Galactus and save the
Earth but either way the Fantastic Four
movie is going to have the Silver Surfer
in it in some way shape or form and
Galactus is going to be hinted at which
is fantastic I believe it it'll probably
be a post-credit scene but let me know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news for live
updates you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof